قال رئيس حركه حماس في قطاع غزه يحيى
السنوار خلال كلمته لمناسبه الذكرى
الخامسه والثلاثون لتاسيس الحركه ان
التنسيق الامنيه لم يحقق للشعب الفلسطيني
الا الفشل وان البندقيه والمقاومه هي
السبيل لتحريره
تنسيق الامني والتسويه لم يحقق لشعبنا الا
الفشل والدمار
ان البندقيه والمقاومه هي السبيل لتحقيقه
اهداف شعبنا
وسلوك العمل الوطني الموحد وكلنا رغم
اختلاف انتماءه التنظيميه اسود في العرين
وبشان الاسرى الفلسطينيين في سجون
الاحتلال قلسوار ان الحركه تمهل الجانب
الاسرائيلي وقتا محدودا لاتمام صفقه تبادل
الاسرى والا فاستغلق ملف اسرى الاحتلال
وتجد سبلا اخرى لتحرير الاسرى الفلسطينيين
على حد تعبير
وقتا محدودا لاتمام هذه الصفقه
خلق ملف اسرى العدو الارض طرف المقاومه
الى ابد الابدين
وسنجد طريقه اخرى
لتحرير اسرانا باذن الله